The missing side length is 27 units. Great work if you found that number.
Again, we'll start with the right triangle and this time we'll have one side of
36 and a hypotenuse of 45. Remember the hypotenuse needs to be right directly
across from the 90 degree angle. This means that this missing side link must be
x. We'll square the legs and sum those together to get the square of the
hypotenuse. So we'll have x squared plus 1,296 equals 2,025. We'll subtract
1,296 from both sides of the equation to get x squared equals 729. Now we can
take the square root of both sides, keeping only the positive root, so x is
equal to 27. The other way to solve this problem is to use the special triangle
3, 4, 5. If we were to multiply each of these numbers by 9, we would get 36 and
we would get 45. This must mean that 9 has to be the multiplier for each of the
side lengths. So to find this missing piece, we simply multiply 3 by 9 to get
27. Again, this is why it's helpful sometimes to know the pythagorean triples.
If you know a couple of them it might make your problem solving easier.